welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
alright we're here in New York City
joining me right now for the Honda dream
garage spring event inside a report is
the man who has been with NBC Sports
with the football morning in America
column now coming up on a year since
he's he moved over there he also the
host of the Peter King podcast and his
football morning in America slash Monday
Morning Quarterback column has been must
read stuff for decades good to see you
Peter King how are you
rich great to be here you bet oh man I
said that I spent a half an hour before
the show taking in this this long read
from Bleacher Report's Tyler done on the
Packers and you said it would took you
the entire train rod down here yeah I
took the subway down from the Upper West
Side and I started at the beginning and
I finished it right when I got off at
Houston streets I'm kind of good and I'm
glad you didn't miss your stop this is
one of those reads it was a great story
by Tyler in journal is in a journalism
sense sense rich the one thing I really
admire about it is that bleacher report
obviously gave Tyler Dunn the time to do
it this is no 1 or 2 weeks story this is
just from reading this story this is a
two to three month investigative story
on what went wrong in Green Bay and the
stuff that he has and the people he
talked to the unfortunate part of the
media today yes is that there's such a
demand to fill the space and such a
demand to feed the monster of NFL
coverage 24/7 12 months a year
that very often really good reporters
are told you got to write five stories
this week and you don't have time to
devote to a story like Tyler done
obviously did so kudos to bleacher
report for giving him the time and Tyler
Dunn is one of the young stars in our
business it's a great story all right so
let's dig into what you obviously have
been around and know about the packers
organization for all these years and and
what what rang most true well what what
came what what did you take from this
long run well the two things that
occurred to me right when I finish the
story are Mike McCarthy's gonna have a
hard time getting a coaching job I mean
first of all if there are eight coaching
I think there are eight coaching jobs
open this year
and if one team interviewed him and the
team who he worked with who now is the
management team in Cleveland didn't
interview him that's telling to me very
very telling and I think the other thing
is going forward will Mike McCarthy
become Brian Billick will he become this
guy you want a Super Bowl and everybody
said yeah you know good coach but didn't
get another shot I mean Brian Billick
really wanted another shot to prove that
the Ravens were wrong in parting ways
with him and he never got the shot now
will Mike McCarthy give the shot and the
other thing that rang true to me is that
remember you know and just recently we
found out that Mike McCarthy our that
Marc Murphy you know who runs the
coaching search now post Mike McCarthy
that that Marc Murphy basically didn't
use Aaron Rodgers as as a sounding board
as hey what do you think Aaron what
would you think if we hired this guy who
was the offensive coordinator at
Tennessee Matt Lafleur what would you
think of this nothing he never asked him
for any input at all and now after
reading Tyler story it becomes painfully
clear why Marc Murphy would not ask
Aaron Rodgers because and again look you
know this is not my story this is Tyler
Dunn's story but if Tyler Dunn's story
is to be believed and I buy it you know
obviously Marc Murphy wouldn't be
skeptical in the opinions of Aaron
Rodgers based on reading this story well
and then so let's put a pin in that for
a second here so they bounced Mike
McCarthy when they fall two for seven
and one for weeks to go they can go on
some sort of run here finish eight seven
and one is that I'm just going through
Marc Murphy's decision-making here to
tell McCarthy to go out and but they
stunk at the time they did they stunk
but there's no way I mean you don't
think that there's no no seeing what not
read in this article no wet we
absolutely I would have done the same
thing that Marc Murphy did I
I read Mike
karthi's comments that the you know I'm
dirty yeah they did all that stuff this
team over the last two and a half years
is the most disappointing team in
football and no one is close for second
place rich just think of this this team
in the last 45 games all right is twenty
one twenty three and one the vast
majority of those games Aaron Rodgers
played so wasn't like Aaron Rodgers
missed two-thirds of those it wasn't
like these are all Brett Hundley losses
a lot of these losses are on Mike
McCarthy and Aaron Rodgers they are a
sub 500 team over two and a half years
with Aaron Rodgers playing it's just
it's a I empathize with McCarthy and I
like Mike McCarthy but they he had no
cause he had no reason to think that
this is a bad decision to fire him with
four games left Peter King here in the
Honda inside a report here on the Rich
Eisen show so what what of the floor
coming in now first head coaching job in
the National Football League you know
the one thing I would say rich is that
the people who know Matt Lafleur are a
little bit worried for him because he's
not a commandant
he doesn't enter a room and he's and be
a commanding presence and I remember
talking to Bill Parcells in January and
Bill Parcells some of these guys he
literally does not know so he doesn't
know for sure who you know what kind of
people they are but he said I'm a little
bit worried about the NFL
decision-making process when coaches are
hired because maybe people think that
that their genius is on one side of the
ball or other he's not he wasn't saying
that oh it's this whole Sean McVeigh
thing he did he wouldn't care if it was
defense you know if it was if it was
somebody who was a brilliant guy on
defense he said you know you have to you
really have to and the reason why Tony
Dungy struggled to get a job for a long
time is that people think he couldn't
Wayne Weaver Jacksonville Jaguars I want
a higher Tom Coughlin because he can
command a room you know and then you go
you listen to Tony Dungy as people after
Tampa Bay and Indianapolis and he walks
into a room and you could hear a pin
drop he just was a quieter guy but
that's the thing I would be concerned
about and we'll see how it goes but Matt
Lafleur it doesn't have the reputation
of being this commanding presence kind
of guy which I still think as a head
coach you need well according to this
article that there was really no
changing Aaron Rodgers mind with
McCarthy because it went all the way
back to the 2006 that's a crazy man that
is that's correct now look I'm not on
the floor doesn't have on his resume
right I understand that but that
particular story I don't doubt the story
but if it's true which I have never
heard one time but I don't doubt it but
if it's true that is crazy talk that's
utterly crazy and if Aaron Rodgers
resented them because of that not cool
on Aaron's part because my a my take on
that though is why is it not cool for
Aaron Rodgers to do that but it's cool
for Brady to say everybody passed on me
I'm a hundred ninety-ninth overall I'm
gonna take it out on everybody and
that's my fire and that if he does sit
there and he thinks this guy never liked
me from the beginning that he doesn't
agree with the play calling he doesn't
agree with this or that the other this
guy never liked me from the beginning
never I mean that's you sound like a
player okay you really do oh he never
liked me Mike McCarthy is paid by Mike
Nolan and I forget was it Trent but it
wasn't Trent Baalke whoever the GM was
at at that time
Scott McLean I really forget who was but
he's paid by those people to say who do
you think is the better quarterback and
he obviously thought at the time that
Alex Smith was the better quarterback
now could Aaron Rodgers be angry about
that to this day of course he could but
in my opinion it's hardly a realistic
way to approach life in my opinion you
know if Menino I applied for jobs coming
out of college and you know the
Pittsburgh post-gazette didn't hire me
out of college so
and the Cincinnati Enquirer did did I
ever say I'll show you Pittsburgh
post-gazette
and I hate them to this day that's
that's I don't know it's just not my
thing
well I mean if it is his thing the
reason why I bring it up here is that
that would have nothing to do with Matt
Lafleur zero right coming it they're
coming in right here where Rogers is 35
but he's gotta find you think don't you
think right that Mike McCarthy had he
been you know I had Chris Simms
you know formerly a bleacher report now
at NBC told me in the last spring when
we were talking about this that might
McCarthy's defenses are offenses
basically were day one right well coast
authorized very very old nothing new and
exciting and imaginative and he can't
believe that they were so primitive this
is Chris Simms yes and so I can't I
can't believe for a second that if Erin
rot that if that if Sean McVeigh does
passed on Aaron Rodgers and Sean McVeigh
became the coach of it of of Aaron
Rodgers that to this day Aaron Rodgers
would say yep Sean McVeigh always hated
that guy because 13 years ago he passed
on me it just it's not realistic what's
realistic is and I by do by this that he
thought that Mike McCarthy was not
helping them become a better football
player
okay so then Lafleur comes in when the
offseason workout program begins as I
imagine next week because he's a new
coach he gets new players he finally
gets to sit down okay think right right
with with Aaron Rodgers well look at
that right now it's this week right so
so he finally gets to sit down with
Aaron Rodgers Lafleur and Rogers gets to
sit down if Aaron Rodgers shows up this
week and I don't know that he is or he
isn't but when they finally sit down I
think my gut feeling is that Rodgers
will be impressed with Lafleur's offense
I think because Lafleur you know is a is
obviously a disciple of Sean McVeigh and
Sean McVeigh believes that everything
new is great and so Aaron Rodgers
totally gonna buy into that now you know
Florida they had a checkered season in
Tennessee you know a checkered season
and it wasn't all great at all and the
quarterback play was certainly not great
so again I'm not I'm not looking to say
this is gonna be trouble at all I'm just
saying I don't know how it's gonna come
out right so I I'm gonna give you a
choice here one of two choices yeah cuz
this is the sports talk radio thing you
there's no such thing as gray hair and
sports what's more likely we look back
five years from now Aaron Rodgers
sensitive stubborn guy who just sabotage
Matt Lafleur and didn't win another
championship in Green Bay and and then
we look back and say it wasn't
McCarthy's fault it was Aaron Rodgers
just being so difficult or Leflore and
Rodgers flourished together they
realized that they need each other and
it becomes it was McCarthy's issue and
they well I don't I think it's I would
choose the latter okay but not saying
well it was McCarthy's issue because I
do think that Rodgers and McCarthy share
responsibility for what has happened in
the last few years but I just think that
Aaron Rodgers understands that he signed
there in Green Bay they're not gonna
show him the door he's not gonna pull an
antonio brown and in my opinion i think
that in sometime in the next five years
the Packers will win a Super Bowl okay
Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
the coach the new head coach under the
most pressure coming up this year would
be Freddy kitchens I mean he's gone from
being America's darling a guy who
thirteen months ago was hired but by
Todd Haley to be his running backs coach
because he needed a running backs coach
not because oh this guy's a brilliant
play caller you know he sort of you know
just sort of almost lucked into being
the offensive play caller because he he
knows the quarterback position so well
and Hugh Jackson worked his way out of a
job so and and hey Freddie kitchens
absolutely unequivocally
you know should be the coach of this
team and he proved that he belonged so
he deserves it don't get me wrong but
all of these improvements it's almost
like if the Browns win ten games and
they're a wild-card team and they lose
the wild-card game it's almost like it
would be a crushing disappointment right
now when what everybody thinks about the
Browns and look I think the Browns have
made all the right moves I mean I
covered them last year rich on draft
time and I knew and I knew totally why
they picked the quarterback and Baker
Mayfield was the right choice at the
time there's no revisionist history here
and he's proven to be a very good choice
and now they've got more pieces in place
so there's a lot of pressure on kitchens
by the way I think if they win ten games
go to the playoffs and lose their first
wild card game it's always difficult for
a first-time quarterback in the pan in
the playoffs to win his first playoff
game I think that would be actually a
very good first year for Fritzie maybe
and maybe that's how it'll turn out but
me looking at it right now right I mean
it's almost like well the brown should
be on in primetime five times
Sunday night should foot but you know
should have them on twice and all that
and it will happen no it's not gonna
happen
you don't think then versus New
England's gonna be on a Sunday night I
don't I don't think it'll be the first
one or or them versus uh them them
versus the the Jets for instance when
when I see gels coming back into MetLife
and what I'm saying what I'm saying is
for the last four years I sat with
Howard Katz on schedule making day yeah
this is only my guess sure I have no
insight it's an educated guess
yes it's an educated guess but my
feeling is last year the San Francisco
49ers were the Cleveland Browns in
always Kyle Shanahan and Jimmy Garoppolo
they're gonna win the division they're
gonna win 12 games blah blah blah blah
there's a lot of flexing and and and and
right now you look back they got four
prime time games right and they got
flexed out of there Sunday night
games right they did they they did not
play on Sunday night because the
quarterback got hurt and I'm not saying
that's what's gonna happen but that's
why I would put the over-under at 4:00
and I would put the over/under on Sunday
night at 1:00 because you all and one
being a home game sure
in Cleveland I do not think Cleveland at
New England will be the opening game of
the season
I don't think so either okay I mean my
guess is it'll be Dallas that's just my
guess but the other thing I would say is
I think the NFL will want to put the
Browns on Sunday night at home just
fairly early in the season maybe against
Pittsburgh maybe against Baltimore but
against a team that there will be a
tremendous of Verve and excitement in
the city for Wow
we're on Sunday Night Football for the
first time in a hundred years that's
what I like Baltimore because I think
the Lamar Jackson versus the Baker
Mayfield twice a year is great obviously
the week 17 was fantastic my choice for
the opening night is Pittsburgh at New
England could be because I want to see
what Pittsburgh looks like yeah
without levy on bail without Antonio
Brown night one in you know everybody
everybody said I bet I got 20 emails
after I said I don't think it's gonna be
Kansas City in New England and I there
were two reasons why it's not going to
be Kansas City in New England in my
opinion it's been Kansas City in New
England on Sunday Night Football for two
straight years right remember opening
day 2017 does and then midseason 2018
plus the moat the biggest marquee
matchup in all of football right now is
Tom Brady and Patrick mahomes the old
and the new yes sir and NBC had it last
year I got to tell you something I will
be shocked if Howard Katz gives it to
NBC gives it to us again this year that
is my guess last one for you here Peter
King you said Freddie kitchens is the
most pressure on him of any first time
head coach what if the Cardinals go
ahead and give Kliff Kingsbury caelum re
I mean that's a huge amount of air it
would put a lot of pressure on him but
there was gonna be pressure on him
anyway because so many people look at
him and say how can a guy who had a
using record in college and get fired in
college and have probably one of the
worst five defenses in all of major
college football over a five-year period
never could build a defense ever and how
can that guy get a head coaching job in
the NFL
walking off you know walking out of
getting fired so I'm not saying that he
they won't take them and there won't be
a lot of pressure arm there will be
there would be a tremendous amount of
pressure on him but I always view a
first-year quarterback no matter how
much hype there is right I view it a
team winning three games a team that had
an awful defense and no offensive line
there's gonna be pressure on them but
they're not a very good team so I don't
I it's not like in Cleveland where I
think the majority of Cleveland Browns
fans majority expect that they will win
the division this year I don't think
anybody expects if the Arizona Cardinals
pick Kyler Murray that they'll win the
division a couple more minutes left here
well with Peter King so have you met
anybody since they come on any breathing
human being since the combine that
thinks Kyle amore is not gonna be
drafted number one overall by ours no
but you know again that's that's sort of
that's recency bias to the enth degree
because look rich saying this is
somebody the other day now that the
draft is on ABC as well as NFL Network
and ESPN there's going to be more live
television coverage of the draft than
there is of the presidential election on
election night
it's totally preposterous but do you
think that the NFL if they haven't said
anything yet do you think the NFL won't
at some point sidle up to Michael bid
will of the Arizona Cardinals and say
whatever you do do not breathe a word to
anyone about what you're going to do and
let's not be dangling Josh Rosen out in
trade talks
a week before the draft well they can't
because they got a they got to make sure
calamari is a living breed
human being at the moment they pull the
trade yeah as soon as they get him but
but but and again I guess I would also
make this point yes I would make this
point I think that it is most likely
although I'm not I I don't have any hard
and fast reasoning but I think it's most
likely that Rosen would go to Washington
or the Giants if he goes to one of those
two teams you've got Bruce Allen who is
excellent at keeping secrets and Dave
gentlemen who's pretty good at it okay
so if you have those two guys yeah it
would be possible for Steve time five
days before the draft or three days
before the draft okay give me your best
offer by 6:00 p.m. on Thursday mmm give
me your best offer for kite for Josh
Rosen and I might call you that night
okay
I like it ask him the poll question
before we send them out the door Chris I
Peter who do you blame him for the
Packers fall to mediocrity Mike McCarthy
the front office Aaron Rodgers yeah I
don't know I I mean it's a classic
everybody deserves it there's not a
person you know that that's a talk radio
question right there that's why you
can't answer the question I'm gonna
chicken out totally because I don't
think it's an answerable question I
think if you asked me to give percentage
on that I would say I'd say you know
probably 40% Thompson because I think he
really got predictable you don't build a
team one way right you don't build a
team all the way through the draft
I think Preston Smith za'darius Smith is
a great free agent you know Daily Double
for this team this year and then but I
also think that McCarthy and Rogers
deserve blame I cannot believe that I'm
saying that the Green Bay Packers with
most of the time Rogers playing had been
under 500 for two and a half years
that's insane so he's changing the front
office if it's 40% down and splits the
other to between 58 30% right but it's
the front office but it's fairly fairly
it's it
Ted Thompson by a nose in the Belma in
the a mile and a half Belmont Stakes
with aaron rodgers and mike mccarthy
down the next down the stretch and down
the stretch they come at Peter
underscore King here on the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience